what were you doing at the moment when
you found out you got the role I was
meeting with Zack and he actually had a
chance to see all the concept art and
all the stuff and basically he was like
you know I want to pitch this idea but
basically do you wanna know what we're
doing we're doing this he took out the
just like sculpture from the dark nights
of the Frank Miller book of Batman and
Superman fighting I was like I am the
luckiest guy in the world
Batman is the coolest part in any
universe good to see you playing well
with others again just looking bad I dig
it maybe temporary
what were you doing at the moment when
you found out you got the role I was in
a small town in Costa Rica Pura Vida and
was eating some sort of delicious fish
and I received a call and it was my
agent
he was very panicked and he said I've
Zack Snyder on the phone he wants to
talk I don't know why Barry Allen Bruce
Wayne you said that like it explains why
there's a total stranger sitting in the
dark my second favorite chair and then
Zack Snyder came on the phone
I'm a big fan your work listen I have
this idea
crazy people with special abilities stop
right there
I'm in and I started having a conniption
[Music]
what were you doing at the moment when
you found out you got the role I was
sitting in an airplane just landed and
then I got the call and then I started
screaming in the middle of the airplane
[Music]
what were you doing at the moment when
you found out you got the role I was in
my apartment and I got a random call
from Zach's assistant saying hey is that
going to talk to you briefly it was like
oh he's probably just calling me to tell
me how well thanks but you know we're
going in a different direction he gets
on the phone he's like so looks like
we'll be making a movie and I go don't
take it from here
do I know you
[Music]
what were you doing at the moment when
you found out you got the role I was in
mr. Schneider's office and he's going I
want you to play someone for me he goes
Aquaman
and I'm Mike pardon me that was the
biggest shot of my life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what did you do this weekend Diana me
nothing very interesting the world
remains in mourning after the death of
the Superman
he said the age of heroes who never come
again it has to
[Music]
we don't have anymore time
[Music]
something is coming
Novacek issues
no language
[Music]
the Kryptonian
[Music]
which made this yeah
like all the others one misses the days
where mums biggest concerns were
exploding wind-up penguins this is crazy
our third thing wrong and I
each of us in some way is held back
don't engage alone until this together
it's really cool you guys seem ready to
do battle and stuff I've never done
battle
relax Alfred I'll take it from here do I
know you
Superman was a beacon to the world
you don't save people and they can see
the best parts of themselves
oh I recognize this way
we don't have to recognize
[Music]
intercepted
[Music]
how many of you are there not enough you
really think today oh wow they just they
really just vanish huh oh that's rude
[Music]
you said you've come now that's hope
you're not too late
[Music]